king kong may be spry for his age but
still he's lived a long time
it's been more than 90 years since his
birth in the mind of miriam c
cooper to the release of godzilla vs
kong and he stayed busy all that time
living a long and complicated life
many hands brought king kong to life but
it all began with miriam c
cooper as outlandish as the movie's
story of lost islands and daring
adventures may seem it's not too far
from cooper's own life
in kong the history of a movie icon from
fay ray to peter jackson author ray
morton chronicles
the director's career in what cooper
called natural dramas documentaries
filmed all over the world then re-shot
and re-cut into narrative form
even the seemingly inexplicable presence
of a movie starlet on a documentary
shoot came from real life
screenwriter ruth rose based the
fictional filmmaker carl denham's
monologue about how every critic and
exhibitor demands a love story on
cooper's own complaints
the discovery of the komodo dragon a
huge primitive reptile that had long
been thought extinct fired cooper's
imagination he conceived a new natural
drama about a war between komodo dragons
and clan of gorillas
eventually whittled down to just one
great ape when cooper learned the
dragons he'd shipped over from komodo
died in captivity he found his tragic
ending
cooper commissioned a script from
mystery writer edgar wallace about a big
game hunter who meets a row boat full of
escaped convicts on a lost island
james a creelman rewrote it replacing
the hunter with a cooper-esque filmmaker
but their studio rko bulked at the cost
of filming live animals in their natural
habitats
fortunately they were also filming a
never finished movie called creation
featuring stop-motion dinosaurs created
by the great willis o'brien and cooper
found the man to bring his kong to life
the original king kong tells the story
of carl denham a filmmaker who journeys
to a mysterious island to document the
legends of a godlike ape with down on
her luck actress ann darrow in tow
upon landing they interrupt a sacrifice
to kong and anne finds herself on the
altar
denim's crew fights their way across the
island and its prehistoric beasts
finally bringing kong back to new york
he escapes of course and drags anne up
the newly built empire state building
then the tallest building on earth until
a fleet of fighter pilots shoots him
down
co-director ernest shaw jack was
horrified to discover he could see the
ways willis o'brien's team disturbed
kong's hair as it jumped around between
frames
morton wrote that he thought the whole
project was sunk until an rko executive
enthusiastically responded look
kong is angry his fur is bristling as
much as cooper and o'brien the credit
for kong's success goes to max steiner
for his pulse-pounding music
but rko was too cheap to commission a
score and only paid steiner to patch
together existing music
cooper paid him out of pocket for an
original composition money well spent
king kong was a monster hit even at the
height of the great depression it raked
in more than 2 million dollars which may
not sound like much after 90 years of
inflation but it adds up to over 40
million in 2021
rko was going to milk this cash cow for
all it was worth and that meant rushing
a sequel into production just nine
months from pitch to release
son of kong is a lot better than you'd
expect under the circumstances
it can't live up to the original but
it's not bad cooper and rose came up
with a surprisingly realistic take on
the aftermath of kong's rampage
with carl denham confined to his
apartment avoiding lawsuits and court
summons
then again they also seem to expect us
to feel more sorry for denim than the
hundreds of people who died as an
all-but direct result of his actions
i brought kong back here he got loose
did a lot of damage got killed and
that's that what can i do about it
we go to jail for 10 years denham flees
a country where he finds a fugitive who
tricks him into helping him escape by
claiming there's a treasure on skull
island
a fanciful claim which improbably turns
out to be true
with the movie already half over they're
off on skull island they finally meet
and befriend the titular son of kong a
smaller lighter colored baby ape
well if it isn't a little calm he's
stuck in a quick sound
he can't get out well i never knew that
old car had a son
then the movie ends with the whole
island falling apart right out of
nowhere and lil kong sacrifices himself
to save denim
rko rushed out son of kong to beat any
knockoffs to the market but that didn't
stop them from coming out later
mighty joe young at least has pedigree
with shaw jack directing a starring role
for armstrong a cooper rose script an
animation by willis o'brien and his
protege ray harryhausen who'd soon
become hollywood's go to stop motion man
conga meanwhile was a cheapy knockoff
with next to no pedigree about a chimp
taking a gross serum that turns him
first into a killer gorilla and then
into a kong sized monster
you could say the same about the
cashians that followed news of the 1976
remake
legendary producers the shaw brothers
took a break from kung fu to produce a
hong kong king kong with the mighty
peking man
also known as goliath a collaboration
between south korea and a small american
studio resulted in a notoriously thrown
together picture called ape
and if you don't believe it's a ripoff
just know that they originally wanted to
call it the new king
kong it at least has one thing no
official kong movie has
we doubt the eighth wonder of the world
ever flipped anyone the bird
beyond the movies we have hannah
barbera's plus size cartoon star grey
babe dc comics titano the super ape a
chimp
who goes monster size thanks to the
powers of kryptonite and rampage the
video game that was later adapted into a
movie starring dwayne johnson
and we can't forget donkey kong the
arcade classic that introduced the world
to mario
even godzilla himself owes a depth kong
it would have been an o'brien-esque
stop-motion creation if money hadn't
been tight and the original godzilla
recreates kong's elevated train attack
so of course they had to meet eventually
tohu's 30th anniversary was a perfect
opportunity
how better to celebrate than to pit the
studio's biggest star against his
american equivalent
king kong vs godzilla was only the third
godzilla movie the first in almost a
decade and it ended up deciding the
direction the franchise would take for
decades to come
the original movie had been a deadly
serious allegory for atomic war but kids
loved the big lizard anyway and this new
movie was designed to appeal to those
young fans
oh hop that kong has no chance
i'll toss you heads for king kong thanks
to godzilla's creator ishiro honda there
was still social commentary
but this time that meant a goofy satire
of tv advertising was some of japan's
biggest comedy stars
in a story about a drug company that
captures kong to be their mascot and
stages a fight between him and godzilla
by carrying
him to the arena with giant balloons not
everyone was happy
according to the book japan's favorite
monster by steve reifel
there were multiple effects artists who
were horrified and some of the goofy
things coordinator iji subbaria expected
them to do
as for kong he's literally big in japan
he grew from small enough to comfortably
interact with the human characters to
godzilla size
not even the odds but also made the
obligatory building climbing scene less
dramatic
since the building is now smaller than
kong
king kong returned to stateside screens
in 1976 thanks to italian super producer
dino de laurentiis
and a script by lorenzo simple jr
creator of tb's batman
after the runaway success of jaws
monsters were big business and both
delaurentis and universal made their own
deals with rko for the rights to the big
eight starting a tug of war that lasted
for years
when the right situation was finally
sorted out dilaurentis released a king
kong for the 70s in which carl denham is
replaced with a scummy oil executive who
wants to
exploit skull islands mineral resources
while jeff bridges plays a hippie
scientist
instead of the empire state building
kong climbs the world trade center
that special effects legend rick baker
in the ape suit but he wasn't too happy
with the final product
it may have been thinking of the scene
when kong bays jessica lang's character
in what looks like a mini golf water
feature
and then blows her dry his cheeks
inflating like big rubbery balloons
i was wrong when i call this thing a
farce it's a tragedy crew had some even
other effects ideas to cut
costs at one point they considered
casting a little person as kong so they
could build even more miniature
miniatures
the 1976 king kong is often remembered
as a flop since it failed in its stated
goal of outperforming jaws but by any
other standards it was a huge hit
making back triple its cost even knowing
that it's hard to imagine anyone was
clamoring for a sequel exactly 10 years
and 2 days later but that's when king
kong lives debuted
how does king kong live exactly because
the university has kept him on life
support all this time and revived him
with a ginormous artificial heart
apparently
but he still lost the will to live so
the scientists bring him a newly
discovered female kong to jolt him awake
by the end there's even a relatively
little baby kong too
dino de laurentiis explained his
rationale to american cinematographer
saying steve mcqueen made a picture in
which he died at the end but they made
another picture with steve mcqueen
many stars die at the end of a picture
and then go on to the next picture kong
is the star
we are going to have a new story a new
kong screenwriter ron shusett discussed
with van goria the many other
possibilities delaurentis considered
which makes the plot they finally went
with looked downright realistic
he shared they had king kong and russia
and king kong in outer space
really this is not an exaggeration lord
of the rings director peter jackson fell
in love with king kong the moment he saw
it on tv
as a small child the 2005 film is
actually his second remake of the story
morton's book reveals jackson had
already recreated it with claymation and
a camcorder at age 12.
universal gave him the chance to mount a
more professional remake on the set of
his first hollywood movie the
frighteners
at first he found the task too daunting
to consider but he changed his mind out
of worry universal would offer the job
to someone else who might do even worse
with it
but the project went on hold until he
followed up return of the king with the
return of another king
as you'd expect from such a devoted fan
jackson's king kong closely follows the
original
keeping the 1933 setting and casting
naomi watts jack black and adrian brody
in the roles originated by fay ray
robert armstrong and bruce cabot
obviously stop motion would never fly in
the digital world of 2005 so jackson
created a motion capture kong with the
help of andy serkis who'd proven the
technology's potential as gollum in lord
of the rings
he and jackson created a more literal
realistic gorilla and whatever you think
of that choice creatively you can't deny
his crew put in the effort
circus who pulls double duty as one of
the sailors in the movies spent weeks in
rwanda studying gorillas in the wild
legendary pictures laid the groundwork
for godzilla vs kong by introducing yet
another version of the eighth wonder of
the world in kong's skull island
like the last remake it's a period piece
but it shifts the action forward to the
70s as a motley crew of vietnam vets a
war photographer and a government agent
arrive on skull island to investigate
and get more than they bargained for
when they meet kong and erects their
helicopters
the ape god's prehistoric world hasn't
been this entrancing since the original
thanks to all kinds of weird creatures
but some of the wildest creatures are
the human ones like john c reilly's
wonderfully unhinged performance as a
fighter pilot who's been stranded on the
island since world war
ii the ewes won't speak their name
but i call them skull crawlers why
because it sounds neat skull island also
gives kong some of the best action
sequences of his whole career building
up to one in which a skull crawler tries
to bite his arm off only for kong to
reach all the way down its throat and
pull its guts out
if this movie's anything to go by the
king's in good hands at legendary
pictures for his return to the screen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one